hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen meine damen und herren hier
beim beschissen kanal auf youtube
heute werden wieder gehirn zerstört
meine lieben freunde denn wir schauen
uns wohl wieder hilf mir an
ich meine wir können ja 2018 nicht enden
lassen nur noch mal darauf reagiert zu
haben super size me mein freund mästet
mich reloaded
ich habe auch schon auf den ersten teil
reagiert ich will doch alles für einen
komischen tut da mein publikum porsche
und auf den zweiten teil habe ich auch
reagiert sehe ich so aus als würde ich
das essen
jetzt haben sich die rtl2 mitarbeiter
gedacht kommen haben wir noch eine
reloaded dritten teil raus also das
jetzt jetzt mein freund mästet mich
reloaded also keine fortsetzung der
bisherigen teile sondern greift die
story auf aber mit neuen schauspielern
bevor wir unsere gehirnzellen komplett
töten einem schauen wir uns mal ein paar
kommentare an ich habe das gefühl ihr
wollt die gehirnzellen von lukas
zuschauern zerstören das gefühl habe ich
auch nächste woche luca reagiert auf
mein freund mich reloaded richtig
erkannt lieber luca hier ist der
gehirnzellen wiederherstellungs knopf so
auf dieses video reagiert hast du
natürlich auch für alle anderen das ist
sehr nett von dir den werde ich auf
jeden fall 4000 mal drücken like wenn
luca darauf reagieren soll hhs lukas
meili tieren ein fall für luca in der
tat hey luca info gehirnzellen werden
hier viele absterben mich langsam
verstanden ich werde das locker drauf
reagiert ilove luca also da waren viele
kommentare dass ich darauf reagieren
soll
und ich habe mich überreden lassen das
heißt meine damen und herren hat er mir
wird schwindelig und wir starten mal
direkt mit der wii action
77 verdammte kutscher das erste mal dass
uns die nackten arsch direkt in die
fresse springt hey was hast du dir dass
du raus gehst
was hast du gemacht hast
da sehen wir haben keine halbe stunde
gegessen warum bist du jetzt schon
wieder ist sie dann nicht irgendwie
sonst equinet schokolade oder chips
nette sprüche bin richtig spektakulär
ist das noch mal ein paar schicken denn
spätere mu lade eigentlich kann ich
wirklich auch mal beihilfe mit spielen
wie kann ich das noch mal hören
[Musik]
ein wahnsinn wahnsinn wahnsinn wirklich
wahnsinn warum bist du jetzt schon
wieder
warum hast du dich schon die arena du
nicht gut kost leute das ist jetzt groß
im abstand die witzigste hilfen erfolg
meiner hat das ist wirklich die
bescheuerte hilfe folge nur 24 sekunden
auf die ich bisher reagiert habe mal
schauen wie es weitergeht das ist doch
nicht normal ja doch kein scheiß
wirklich nutzt sie die zitty
heftige schauspielerin verkörpert die
rolle perfekt ich glaube ihr wisst alle
dass es nicht gegen die person
persönlich gehen soll oder gegen die
schauspieler aber hey office wahnsinn
das ist unterhaltung auf dem anderen
milchstraßen system
ich wollte die wäsche ruhe
was hast du zu verbergen anziehsachen
die sache was macht die tür auf ganz
kurz was geht hier ab das ist alles seit
mehr als einer minute die gleiche szene
ich habe das noch nie gesagt aber das
ist zum ersten mal
schauspielerisch brett geil
ihr könnt ja doch was bei rtl
[Musik]
ich mein wenn ich mein bett jeder tag
ist kann das nicht mehr freunde diese
serie tötet mich ich glaube wenn ich
doch mal studieren würde ich würde mein
studiengang mich nochmal schaffen
irgendwas stimmt nicht mit dir
freunde ich habe mir eigentlich gesagt
hey kommen ich habe genug auf hilfen wie
reagiert er mit gibt andere leute die
das jeden tag machen aber eine folge
dachte ich mir kommen so als geschenk
von jahresabschluss ja das ab schluckte
häuser der 31 erstmalig allen schon mal
guten rutsch könnt ihr auch mal gerne in
die kommentare schreiben
guten rutsch luca würde mich freuen weil
ich mir das keiner
meine freundin und ich dachte mir auf
jeden fall zur feier des tages hey komm
reagiert noch mal auf hilf mir mein
freund mich kann man ganz gut an bei
euch und deswegen dachte ich mir hey
professor doktor
m durch diese brille
da wird man echten bis wir schauen mal
weiter so gut wie sowas
und so wie meine mutter mal einkaufen
dachte irgendwas vernünftiges
herauskommt die an gesundem beutel
voller gemüse und was sie eigentlich
dass mit tobi jetzt schon bisher hat man
gesehen dass wir dann auch und was kommt
dann wieder von ihr will irgendwas nicht
tobi ist wahrscheinlich der freund der
sie mästen oder du kannst das gefühl
hunger oder beste antwort wenn der sagt
dass sie scheint aber ich würde
interessieren werden durch dann so auf
putzen wird für mich sein
ist nicht irgendjemand ja wenn ich die
beide auf der straße würde ich würde
dich einfach daneben stellen und lachen
ich bin und ich bin ja schwanger und
keine ahnung
mit meiner geduld ist es wie mit seinem
wasserglas dann füllt wasser rein und
irgendwann ist es halt die perfekte
menge und wenn man weiter überfüllt
überschwemmt dann hat man eine kleine
pfütze bei mir ist dieses mittlerweile
so groß wie der atlantik irgendwohin
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
wirklich freunde lasst bei diesem video
daumen hoch da denn
ja keine ahnung macht das einfach alfie
ist ihrer tochter nach dem streit
gefolgt sie was ich meine
ganz ehrlich da muss ich wohl für körper
und ich werde bis überhaupt gar nicht so
dick dass es jetzt sehr mit tobias
kennen kann man schon ich werde ganz
kurz
das ist bisher die beste hilfe in folge
die ich gesehen habe die schauspieler
sind klasse also die verkörpern ihre
rollen perfekt und vor allem diese
aufnahmen die er hinter einem vorhang
durch einen spiegel das sind ja so
klassische filmische thematisch ich habe
keine ahnung von sowas aber echt cool
aus hier ganz kurz übrigens hoffe dass
meine haare so komplett durcheinander
sind dabei müssten gerade vögel darin
dafür müsstest du auch im osten bisschen
mehr zulegen
es ist doch so viel kann ich versprechen
das schlecht wäre auf jeden fall weil
das gut doch viel besser zur geltung
hier und ihr freund
ist tattoo mensch macht auch genannt im
wenn man deutsch kann also es ist jetzt
nicht so wie bei den ersten beiden
teilen dass da wirklich ein mädchen
gezwungen wird und messen den mund
gesteckt wird sondern er arbeitet und
sagt ihr sie soll zudem und sie will es
dann auch wahnsinn ich bin gespannt wie
es weitergeht ich bin allerdings auch
als ehrlich mit euch freuen ich bin
jetzt bei meiner reaction hier bei 43
minuten aufnahme und wir sind gerade mal
minute 7 und 13 anhalt also wollt ihr
dass ich da noch einen zweiten teil
mache und auf den rest der folge
reagiere schreibt mir gerne unten in die
kommentare ob ich eventuell in ein paar
tagen auf den rest dieser mein freund
mich reloaded superstars erste hilfe im
volk er war reagieren soll
ansonsten will ich das video an der
stelle toppen meine damen und herren ihr
merkt ja dass ich mit dem hilfen mehr
action krams videos auf seinem kanal ein
bisschen zurück gefahren bin habe tun
sei ich kann echt kamen 1
mein handy ist gerade vom tisch gefallen
aber es noch heile
übrigens kriegt man das pop socket ich
wird das video ist allerdings auch
endlich beenden meine lieben freunde was
ich da noch sagen wollte ich habe in
letzter zeit ein bisschen weniger auf
hilfen reagiert weil main kanal bestand
noch daraus so das ist gerade glaube ich
meine zehnte reaction dazu oder so ich
möchte ein bisschen mehr wieder eigenen
content machen das habe ich mir so
gesagt für 2009/10 ich hoffe ihr
versteht das wenn die ideen für videos
habt könnt ihr auch gerne und in die
kommentare schreiben
und jetzt kommt das outro rutschig
übrigens hoffentlich rückständig audi
[Musik]